grands honneur et amitié pour le Premier
ministre de l'Ukraine juste un Trudeau
veut signaler que le Canada n'a pas
oublié son pays on va continuer d'être
la police soutenir aussi longtemps qu'il
le faudra
de la parole aux actes juste un Trudeau
annonce l'envoi de 21000 fusils d'assaut
et des millions de munitions à l'Ukraine
de nouvelles sanctions contre une
cinquantaine de personnes et entités
russes les deux pays resserre aussi leur
lien commerciaux et énergétique mais les
besoins de l'Ukraine sont beaucoup plus
grands
une contre-offensive nous avons besoin
d'armement supplémentaire insiste le
Premier ministre ukrainien sont
détaillés publiquement ces demandes son
pays notamment demandé des avions de
chasse aux alliances ce qui n'est pas
dans les plans du Canada pour le moment
malgré tout l'heure est à la
reconnaissance
semble avoir trouvé le moyen de jouer
les troubles fêtes pendant la visite du
dignitaire ukrainien
les cyber pirates prorus ont revendiqué
des attaques contre plusieurs sites Web
du gouvernement du Canada le site web du
Premier ministre canadien par exemple a
été en panne pendant plusieurs heures
juste un Trudeau à minimiser l'incident
le fait que pendant quelques heures il y
a une page du gouvernement qui a été
difficile à accéder
ne va pas nous dissuader en rien mais de
possible faille de sécurité plus
inquiétante encore ont été révélés ces
derniers jours dans la fuite de
documents classifiés du Pentagone des
cyberpirates russes auraient réussi à
s'infiltrer dans les systèmes
informatiques d'une société canadienne
de gazoduc sont réfutés ces allégations
Justin Trudeau fait une mise au point je
peux confirmer qu'il n'y a eu aucun
dommage physique à des installations
canadiennes impossible de savoir si les
cyberpirates ont réussi à prendre le
contrôle de certaines installations peu
importe l'affaire préoccupe cette expert
oui c'est très simple
qui s'ingent dans les opérations
économiques de notre pays ça ne devrait
pas avoir lieu même si c'est seulement
faire la collecte d'information les
cyber-attaques envers le Canada servent
de rappel la menace russe dépasse les
frontières de l'Ukraine de quoi donner
des arguments à Justin Trudeau qui
continue de prôner une approche ferme
face à Moscou ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada Ottawa